all right ted thank you from zoom
fatigue to the
never ending stream of work emails a lot
of people are really trying to find the
balance
with working at home i know while i'm
working at home sometimes
one of kids has a zoom ballet class
another kid has a zoom
piano class and uh if you hear
chopsticks in the background that's what
it is
kirsten joyce joins us live i feel
kirsten is like it's the the battle of
the wi-fi if you will
we're all trying to find balance in this
crazy year we certainly are i suffer
from that too at times brian well
we caught up with the co-founder of
clockwise matt martin
he shared insight on how workers can
take back control of their calendar
and find balance now that the lines
between work and life have kind of been
blurred
when the pandemic first hit he said
everybody sheltered in place there was
actually a spike in meetings
and a reduction overall in the amount of
time people had to actually do their job
hours started to stretch because people
didn't have the reminder of
leaving the office martin started
clockwise pre-pandemic
to help make time more manageable he
finds it's become a very useful tool for
people as the meeting culture has now
shifted
what clockwise does at its core is it
connects your calendar
and it helps to understand exactly how
you're using your time but also how your
colleagues are using their time
and then we'll give you a set of
recommendations for how you can optimize
your schedule
um it can be things as light as hey this
would be a good block to set aside for
what we call focus time
or it can become as automated as you
know you giving
us control giving clockwise control of
the timing of a certain meeting
in order to make it flexible and we will
automatically move that meeting
it's the best time available for all
attendees in order to facilitate the
best schedule for you
clockwise is completely free program for
individuals
but for the larger team settings there
is a monthly charge associated with it
brian kirsten we reached out to viewers
asking on twitter what has your work
experience been like
60 say easy 40
say difficult the 40 percent has
toddlers denise
yeah for sure doing distance learning
and working from home that is tough